just some breaking news right now Julie
FIFA Sepp Blatter has now been elected
to the fifth term as FIFA president
Prince Ali has withdrawn his name from
the race is that effectively handed him
the presidency but as our Brendan really
was telling us in a surprise it took two
rounds to do this that's something that
a lot of people didn't think was gonna
happen because the first time he needed
X amount of votes to third second round
he needed a simple majority and Brendan
really who has been kind enough to
scurry back to the set are you surprised
by this outcome not completely so he we
didn't actually go to a second we're
sorry we went to a second round but they
didn't revote the second round it was
clear that there was no way that 73
votes which by the way nobody expected
in the first place within the short time
they had to renegotiate the votes was
going to get to the absolute majority
that Prince all he needed what we found
out here is that Sepp Blatter is much
though still president is much weaker
than anybody had anticipated that these
scandals I mean he has a survivor and
these this scandal has really weakened
him so this was not to become why not
right i mean this comes at a week when
there are nine indictments here right
for corruption why not why wouldnt why
wouldn't he be because there's been
right there have been there have been
both allegations and convictions in the
past I mean this is not news to anybody
who's followed this organization so he
has managed to brush it off before um he
he has been much less successful bicep
bladder standards of brushing it off and
there have been people now who have come
out in public and said things that they
were too scared to say before I think
that makes a big difference Brendan I
have to ask a question because even with
the indictments the arrest as Betty
mentioned the charges against some of
these FIFA officials a lot of people are
saying we are really talking about
football we're talking about sports tell
people why this matters outside of the
realm of sports because sports are a way
to express power so it has been very
important for Vladimir Putin to get the
Olympics and to get the World Cup we
suspect that he got the World Cup
basically by arranging it and by the way
he is masterful at managing FIFA he has
been back in
with and back and forth for a decade
making sure that that relationship with
both the International Olympic Committee
and FIFA both those relationships are
locked down Gazprom is now a title
sponsor what they call a partner of FIFA
that is not an accident that is a 25 we
think million dollar payment that is
part of a way of showing his generosity
so these things are important to power
so when you give somebody an event like
this when you give a country an event
like this it's a way of stamping that
country with legitimacy so there's
tremendous hustling around these votes
it's important to note that usually the
vote for where the next world cup is
going to take place happens one cup by
one cup the cup that the vote that in
2010 push the two cups the one that
guitar eventually got and the one that
Russia eventually got it pushed them
together so that there could be very
efficient vote trading so this is not
about soccer this is about power it's a
great question market and and Brendan a
great point I want to get to mark Barton
though who is standing by right now
we've just got him ready who is giving
us the aftermath the immediate aftermath
of this news here that Sepp Blatter has
been reelected to a fifth term mark you
said it Betty five terms running hilsa
probably for over 20 years that's a long
duration after the fourth occasion he
said he wouldn't run again will he go
for a sixth term Betty that's the big
question for Miss for Prince Ali to have
won the second round he would have had
to have had a 40-percent swing I racked
my brain Betty this is one for Brendan
by the way and in the UK election there
were some forty percent swings in the
Scottish votes in the election it's very
unlikely though a 40-percent swing
that's why Prince Ali step down Blatter
is king we predicted it there wasn't
going to be an election shock of the
size of the UK election or the Israeli
election but this story runs and runs
don't forget it because the indictment
has happened that's gonna play out and
as my guest said gido Tong yani the
former fifa executive other Federation's
could
could could be under the microscope as
well from investigators around the world
it's not going to be an easy fifth turn
for mr. Blatter